واللغه العربيه وجمالها في تفردها
ومفرداتها نحن سنجرب معكم قراءه هذه
الابيات العجيبه من اللغه العربيه نبدا
معكم في البيت الاول
وقبر حربا بمكان قفر وليس قرب قبر حرب قبر
القبر هنا يعني المكان الخالي الذي لا شيء
حوله ودلاله البيت ان القبر لا شيء حوله
فهو في مكان بعيد لوحده
الم الم الم بدائه ان ان ان ان اوانه هذا
من اصعب ابيات المتنبي شرحه يطول جدا
ويتحدث عن الالم بطريقه عجيبه ليس معها
اشواق
كان كان صعب وقدرتي تنجحي في المهمه وهذا
التحدي فتى فتن في فتاه فتاهها وبات بسبب
الفتاه فتاه اظن هذا البيت اشهر من
البيتين السابقين لكن مترادفات فيه كثيره
وهنا كان الاعجاز والابداع الادب صادق
صديقا صادقا في صدقه فصدق الصداقه في صديق
صادق كذلك هذا البيت هو الشاعر بسيط لكنه
كثير المترادفات نجحنا في التحدي نجحنا
ونصف ههه
الوطن العربي ونشوف مين نجح في تحدي اللغه
العربيه في محاولات مصر العراق والاردن
قراءه بعضنا الجمل العربيه الساحره من
الشعر العربي نتابع ونرى من الفائز
بالتحدي العربي
[موسيقى]
صادق صديقا صادقا في صدقه
الصداقه في صديق صادق
في فتاه
وبات بسبب الفتاه
[موسيقى]
ههه فتن في فتان فتاه وبات بسبب الفتاه
فتاه صادق صديق صادق في صدقه فصدقه
الصداقه في صديق صادقه
[موسيقى]
ده ده عربي جديد ده عربي اول مره اشوف
الرقابه القبر وليس قرب قبر حرب قبر ان ان
ان ان هو انا فتى فتى في فتاه فتاه وبات
بسبب الفتاه وبات بسبب الفتاه
صادق صديقا
[موسيقى]
وقبر الحرب في مكان قفري وليس قربه قبر
حرب قبل
فتاه
وبات بسبب الفتاه
صادق صديقا صادقا في صدقه فصدق الصداقه في
صديق صادقا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وليس قرب قبر حرب قبر الم الم بدائه ان ان
ان
اوانه فتى في فتاه فتاه وبات بسبب الفتاه
صادق صديقا صادقا في صدقه فصدق الصداقه في
صديق صادقا
[موسيقى]
فتاه فتاه ابات بسبب فتاه قبل حرب في
مكاني قفر وليس قرب قبر فتاه في فتاه فتاه
ومات بسبب الفتاه الفتاه
قفري وليس بقبر قبر فتاه في فتاه فتاه
صادقا
في صدقه
فصدق في صداقه في صديق صادقا
[موسيقى]